CHRIS: Meathead is the author
of the book "Meathead--
The Science of Great
Barbecue and Grilling,"
which I'm told is currently
the number four bestselling
cookbook on Amazon.
He is also the founder and
editor of amazingribs.com,
which is a fantastic website.
Honestly, I bought my
first smoker this summer.
And I cannot count the number
of times that I've ended up
on amazingribs.com just
Googling for something.
Like this past
weekend, I wasn't sure
how to know when
the ribs are done.
So I searched for
how ribs are done.
I ended up on his website.
And I learned all
about the bend test.
So Meathead's here to--
[APPLAUSE]
So anyway, Meathead is
here to bust some myths
and to tell us all the
rest of his secrets
beyond the bend test.
Please welcome Meathead.
[APPLAUSE]
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN:
Thank you so much.
It's a real pleasure
privilege to be here.
I wouldn't be here
without the great love
and respect Google search
has given my website.
And thanks, Chris, for the
first person testimonial there.
The book is called "The Science
of Barbecue and Grilling."
And that, I think, might
appeal to some of you.
We are in the year 2016.
It is an age of technology.
And we really
wanted to know what
happens under the hood of
the grill and the smoker.
If you've ever been
to Austin or if you
know much about barbecue,
the hottest restaurant
in the country is
Franklin BBQ in Austin.
And I was thrilled to hear
Aaron Franklin say in his book
that mine is an amazing
compendium of barbecue
knowledge.
It's really a lifelong
labor of work and effort.
It's about 400 pages,
400 photographs.
I did most of the
photography myself.
The chapter titles are
"The Science of Heat."
We talk about the three
different kinds of heat
that you'll deal
with on a grill.
"The Science of Fire",
"The Science of Smoke."
There are different
kinds of smoke.
There are good tasting
smoke and bad tasting smoke.
We'll touch upon
that a little bit.
There's some meat
science, food science.
What is in meat?
What is in vegetables?
What happens when
meat hits heat?
There is a lengthy discussion
of hardware, the different types
of grills and smokers.
Which work?
Which don't work?
And accessories and gadgets,
because the one with the most
gadgets wins.
And there's a lot of technique.
It's about 400 pages, and about
the first half of the book
is this textual or
background information
that if you buy the book-- and
you should, and Father's Day is
just around the corner-- you
want to start at the beginning.
Because it makes sense.
It flows.
As much as we all
love the internet,
I hear from a lot
of people who might
Google how to cook a brisket.
They find my site.
They go to the brisket page.
They click on a link.
They jump to another page.
And they start
gathering knowledge.
But there's big holes
when you're jumping
around using hyperlinks.
And the book, you know, there's
still a place for a dead tree.
And it flows in a sequence.
And I'm very pleased with
the way the book flows.
So I'd recommend it.
And then something that we'll do
today-- a lot of myth busting.
I'm not a scientist.
But I've worked with a number
of scientists that help me.
I was a journalist by training.
And journalists and scientists
have one thing in common.
My wife is a scientist.
She's a very high
ranking food safety
expert for the FDA, a PhD.
And as a journalist,
we're both trained
to ask, how do you
know that to be true?
How do you know that?
When people say, and in
this political season,
that's a good question
for us all to be asking.
How do you know that to be true?
Can you prove that?
And that's a question
I'm constantly asking.
Because I learned to
barbecue from dad.
I went out back
with him first time
probably eight, nine
years old, and watched
him grill up some beef ribs.
And it was wonderful.
And I loved it.
And the fact that he might
have let me have a sip of beer
while he was cooking might
have piqued my interest a bit.
But it was great fun.
I learned to grill from dad.
And he learned to
grill from his dad.
And there's these
old husband's tales,
I call them, that
are passed down
from generation to
generation of backyard cooks.
And we started asking, how
do you know that to be true?
And we found that a lot of them
aren't true, that a lot of them
don't hold water, don't work.
So in addition to the myth
busting and the science, then
there's about 118
recipes starting
with brines, rub sauces, all the
meat groups, and side dishes.
And they kind of
exemplify that which
is in the technique section.
And then, of course,
my website, if you
run into a question in the
book, I and our moderators--
and we pay our moderators, which
is most unusual for websites.
We actually pay them.
There's a really talented team.
We're in there every day
answering questions 24/7.
If you ask a question
at 2:00 in the morning,
you might have to wait a
little bit for an answer.
But we really try to
hold people's hands.
We get a lot of
questions like, help.
I've got the meat
on the grill now.
And it's not going
up in temperature.
And the guests are
coming in 15 minutes.
What do I do?
Happy to be there.
Happy to do that.
We do it all the time.
And the website has about
1,000 pages-- again,
recipes, technique.
And we have buying
guides in there.
So if you're in the market
for a grill or a smoker,
here's a job description.
If you ever get tired of working
at Google, which is obviously
a great place to
work-- and please
don't misinterpret this as
me trying to pirate anybody.
But there's a guy who works
for me who's got the best job
title in the world.
Max Good, we call him
keeper of the flame.
But his job is testing
grills and smokers.
That's it.
That's his job.
He just goes out back, fires it
up, puts in the thermometers,
puts in the testing and
gear, cooks a bunch food,
writes notes, writes reviews
of grills and smokers.
Cool job.
I wish I had it.
And we also have an
electrical engineer
who tests thermometers.
We'll talk about
thermometers in a minute.
But thermometers are one of
the most important things
you can have as a outdoor
or an indoor cook.
And we have a guy who tests
them against factory specs.
So there's buying guides.
And we have community.
We have a section called
the pit master club.
Actually, I'll talk
about this briefly.
I don't get to talk about it.
But this is an audience
that might appreciate this.
We do not have a
major publishing
company that owns us.
We do not have a network
television show that owns us.
We're free standing.
I founded it myself in
2005 with pocket money.
I've had no debt.
It's always been profitable.
Thank you, Google.
And our new business model is we
set up a special section called
the pit master club.
It costs $24 a year.
And we have about 14,000 members
in the past year joined in.
It's a little more
than a year old.
You can do the math.
That's a working business
model for a small business.
And the pit master
club has a community
and a lot of fun stuff in it.
So we are finding
ways to make a living
as advertising rates
nosedive and other revenue
streams are problematic.
I wrote the book and the website
with the help of Professor Greg
Blonder.
His name is on the cover.
He's our science advisor.
He's an engineer at
Boston University.
He used to be head of
research at Bell Labs.
And he's a food scientist,
physicist, engineer,
really remarkable man.
Dr. Mata, who's
a meat scientist.
My wife, Dr. Tortorello,
who's a food safety expert.
I have a Culinary Institute
trained chef to tests recipes.
So it's a really good team.
And anybody here know
the name Kenji Lopez-Alt?
Yeah, yeah.
I see a few hands go up.
Kenji wrote a book that
came out last fall called
"The Food Lab."
And it is phenomenal.
If you don't have
it, you need it.
It's probably
better than my book.
It's about 800 pages.
It's really good food science.
Unfortunately, when Kenji wrote
it, he lived here in New York.
He didn't have a backyard grill.
So there's nothing about
barbecue and grilling in there.
So my book makes
a good companion.
He wrote the forward.
And it is just dynamite.
It's my favorite
cookbook right now.
That's it there.
What's interesting going on
in the culinary world right
now is that there have
been food writers forever.
But there's this new genre
of food writers emerging.
It started with the food
scientist Harold McGee
and Shirley Corriher.
They're are grandparents.
And Alton Brown, everybody
here knows Alton Brown,
Christopher Kimball from
"Cooks Illustrated",
Kenji, Nathan Myhrvold
from "Modernist Cuisine",
the ChefSteps
people in Seattle--
we're all really
into teaching people
what happens when you cook.
We no longer want just a recipe.
How do you do this?
What do I do?
Tell me step one,
step two, step three.
We want to know why.
Why am I doing this?
Why is this happening?
And why call us the nerdists?
In the art world you have the
cubists and the modernists
and the impressionists.
Well, we're the nerdists
in the culinary world.
And there's more and
more of us coming around.
You'll see this.
It's a trend in cookbooks.
So that's kind of the direction
that the website and the book
are going.
So rather than give you
a chat on everything
I know about barbecue--
because that's in the book--
I thought I'd take on the
subject of these old husband's
tales, take on a few of the
more popular endearing, enduring
myths that many of
you probably hold,
and see if we can bust
them to smithereens.
Let's start with thermometers.
The myth-- thermometers
are for sissies.
I don't need a thermometer.
I can tell when it's done by
poking it or cutting into it.
The thing you need to have
when you're cooking is control.
You need control of every
little aspect of the process.
But most of all, you need
control of temperature.
You need to know what
temperature the oven is.
temperature the food is.
A medium rare steak
is 130-135 degrees.
It's not 140 or 120.
It's 130 to 135.
At medium rare,
the food scientists
with the fake jaws that
chew meat and tell us
how much resistance and
how much moisture it
has have taught us
that medium rare
is when steak is at its
most juicy and tender.
We didn't need a
machine to tell us that.
If you love steak, you
know that intuitively.
So if you want your
steak medium rare,
you don't put it out
there and cook it
for eight minutes on one
side and five minutes
on the next side.
Because you have no idea if
that's going to be adequate.
The temperature of that meat
is dependent on its thickness.
The thicker the
meat, the longer it
takes for the heat to be
transmitted down to the center.
Now, the hot air doesn't cook
the interior of the meat.
It can't get in there.
The hot air cooks the
outside of the meat
and only the
outside of the meat.
As the outside of
the meat heats up,
it transmits the heat
down towards the center.
So the outside of the meat
cooks the inside of the meat.
The thicker the
meat, the longer it
takes for the energy to
move towards the center.
So you can't take a recipe
that says five minutes
on one side, four
minutes on the other
unless you know how thick it is.
And of course, the other big
variable is the temperature.
What is the air temp?
And air temp is important.
But I mentioned there's
different types of heat.
When we cook on a grill,
you have air temp, which
is the convection airflow.
You have conduction, which is
the temperature of the metal.
The metal is about 8,000 times
more energy than the air.
And then there is
radiant heat or infrared
heat that comes from the
coals or the gas jets.
And they are different
heats with different levels
of energy.
And the best way
to understand this
is go out and fire up your grill
and bring it up to about 225.
That's not too hot.
That's a good number
by the way to try
to shoot for most cooking.
Now, lift the lid and
put your arm in there.
You can actually hold your
arm in 225 for a little while.
It doesn't burn too much.
It's warm in there.
But you can hold it in
there, maybe for a minute.
Or do it with your oven inside.
Now, put your hand on
the cooking grates.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it's 225.
When you get back
from the hospital,
you'll know that
everything that's 225
doesn't have the same
amount of energy.
Air conducts less
energy than metal.
Water conducts energy at a
different rate than metal,
so does oil, frying.
So they all can conduct
energy at different rates.
And so you need to know
what you're doing with them.
And the best way to know
is with thermometers.
Now this shouldn't
come as a shock
to a technologically
oriented audience like you.
But you would not believe how
many knuckle draggers there
are out there who just say,
I don't need no thermometers.
They're for sissies.
This is 2016.
You can get really good
digital thermometers.
The top of the line is
something called the Thermapen.
And it takes about
two seconds to read
the temperature of your meat.
So you can stick it in the
meat, and in two seconds,
you get a percentage number.
And you know if it's medium
rare or not or well-done.
And as you back it
out gently-- It's
got a little tiny sensor too.
It's really small.
So you can actually
back it out of the meat
and take progressive
readings as you go.
It costs about $100.
You don't have to spend $100.
There's another one
called the Thermal Pop.
It looks like a little lollipop.
It costs $30.
And it takes five
seconds to read.
So $30 for five seconds,
$100 for two seconds.
Both of them are great.
You've seen the
Thermapen on television.
A lot of the cooking
shows, the chefs use them.
Go get yourself a really
good digital food thermometer
so you know exactly the
temperature of your food.
Because you can't poke
the meat and tell.
Now, if I work in
Morton's Steakhouse,
and I'm cooking the same
steaks, cut the same thickness
from the same cattle
in the same ovens
every night the same way,
yeah, I can poke the meat,
and I can tell.
But I'm a pretty good cook.
And I cook outdoors a lot.
And I cannot tell
for sure by poking.
Because a sirloin feels
different than a filet mignon.
And my hand-- this
is the silly one--
all the books say, well,
if your hand is flexed
like this, that's medium rare.
And if you clench your
fist, that's medium.
And if you clench it
harder, that's well done.
I mean, everybody's
hand is different.
Fat guys' hands feel different
than skinny guys' hands.
A person who works out feels
different than a person who
doesn't.
So thermometer is
the only way to go.
And if you really want
to do it up right,
you want to get yourself
another thermometer
not just for the meat,
but for the oven.
And a grill, by the way, or a
smoker is just an outdoor oven.
So you want to get
a thermometer that
has a probe that you
can sit next to the meat
on the grill surface.
That thermometer on your
grill, that dome thermometer,
when the guy who's in
charge of purchasing
for the grill company, he's
given a really small budget.
And he buys the cheapest
thermometer he can buy.
And it's a piece of junk.
Just put duct tape over it.
Ignore it.
Among other things,
it's up in the dome.
And the food is down here.
Now, if you plan to eat
the dome, it's useful.
But you're going
to eat the food.
So you want a probe that
you can place near the meat.
And by the way, don't
place it too close.
Because there's a cold air
bubble right around the meat.
You want to put it about
two inches away or an inch
away next to the
meat on the surface.
And now you know the temperature
of the air the meat is feeling.
So you know what
you're cooking at.
Now you have control.
This is an example.
I've written this for years,
and readers have been sending me
pictures of their digital
thermometer compared
to the dial thermometer
on their grill.
And you can see to the
left, 297 versus 397,
an even 100 degrees off.
254 versus 210.
Can you imagine if
you cooked indoors
if your thermostat
was that far off?
I mean, it usually
is a little off.
But that far?
100 degree difference?
You need to know with a
digital thermometer what
your temperature is.
And also, get yourself a
good meat temperature guide.
We published a small one
like this that you can buy it
on Amazon for $5.00.
And there's a big
long one that's
got all kinds of
numbers on it for $10.
And it's magnetic, stick
to the refrigerator door.
Now you know the temperatures
that USDA recommends.
And the chart also gives
you the temperatures
that chefs recommend, which
is often different than what
USDA recommends.
OK, here's another myth.
Cook the chicken until
the juices run clear.
Cooks in the audience, I presume
most of you are cooks, right?
You know this.
You cook the chicken.
You slice into it.
And by the thigh bone, right
down by the thigh bone,
you've seen that, haven't you?
That ugly purple bloody
looking down by the thigh bone.
There's a reason that's purple.
And it's not unsafe.
If you cook it to 160-165
degrees, it's safe.
If you use a
thermometer, it's safe.
The reason it's
purple down there
is chickens go from
egg to grocery store
shelf in seven and a half
weeks, often just seven weeks.
Three and a half pounds
of growth, from zero
to three and a half pounds
in just under two months.
I mean, that's
phenomenal growth rate.
And they're not allowed
to use hormones.
They've just fine
tuned the breeding
and the feeding
of these animals.
The problem is the bones haven't
had a chance to fully calcify.
They're not hard all around.
They're still soft.
These are like babies.
The bones aren't hard.
And blood is manufactured
inside the bones.
And you see this particularly
on the thigh bone.
Ugly and scary as that
look, that chicken is safe.
I measured the temp.
It was 180 actually.
160 to 165 is safe,
well over safe temp.
Only a thermometer will
tell you if it's safe.
So of course, my wife, the food
safety expert, knows all this.
But if I bring in a chicken
like this and I say,
honey, I swear I used
my $100 Thermapen.
It's 181.
160's safe.
She'll pop it in the microwave.
Pink chicken is kind
of weird, isn't it?
Another myth-- follow
recipe cooking times.
So they'll tell
you-- this graphic
is your Christmas roast.
That's your prime
rib roast, right?
It's about 10 inches long,
about four inches thick.
And that's a seven
bone roast on the top.
And they'll tell you cook it
for eight minutes a pound.
I don't know what
they say it is.
But they'll give you
a number, depending
on the temperature of your
oven, how many minutes per pound
to cook it.
But the funny thing is, is
the top one, the second one,
and the third one all take
the same time to cook.
Yet they weigh vastly
different amounts.
And the reason they take
the same time to cook
is they're all
four inches thick.
So the heat moving from
the outside to the center
takes the same amount of time.
So the weight is not the
determining factor in how long
it takes to cook.
It's the thickness
that matters the most.
Now, the bottom one will
cook faster because it's
only three inches wide.
So that's the narrowest
diameter instead of four inches.
It'll cook faster.
Cool, huh?
Searing seals in the juices--
another long lasting myth.
We can't get rid of it.
Started by some guy back
in the 1800s in Germany.
And it just won't go away.
Meat fibers are not balloons.
They don't fill up with water.
And when you put them
overheat, they just clamp shut,
and the juices won't come out.
These are two steaks
that you can see here.
They're seared well.
They're brown on the surface.
And there's juices
on the surface.
The searing does not
seal in the juices.
And in fact, if you take two
steaks, identical, cut side
by side from the same piece of
me, weigh the same, sear one
first, don't sear the other.
Put them in the oven
or in the grill.
And cook them to the same
internal temperature.
Bring them out and weigh them.
The seared one will weigh less.
It'll have more moisture loss.
Why?
Because it's hotter.
When you sear, heat
drives moisture out.
But don't worry.
An eight ounce steak
contains six ounces of water.
It's 70% to 75% water.
You can stick a
thermometer in it.
It's not going to go--
[WHISTLE]
--and deflate.
You can even turn
it with a fork.
And all the books
say, no, no, no.
Don't do that.
Don't [INTENTIONALLY MUMBLES].
They'll arrest you if
you-- Tongs are better.
But you're not going to
lose that much moisture.
An eight ounce filet mignon
has six ounces of water in it.
Not to worry.
Searing does not
seal in the juices.
But searing is important.
Searing is wonderful.
Brown is beautiful.
When you're cooking, you
want brown on the surface.
Brown is a result of
the Maillard reaction
and caramelization--
two chemical reactions.
Maillard reaction is
proteins and amino acids
with some sugars.
Caramelization is mostly sugars.
But regardless of the
chemistry involved,
the surface of the meat or
the potato or the asparagus
or whatever you're cooking,
the surface changes chemistry.
The heat alters the
chemistry of the surface.
So what you end up with is a
lot of new chemical compounds
that are really flavorful.
You really like the
taste of seared foods.
So you do want to sear.
Don't worry about the
little bit of moisture loss.
There's plenty of
moisture left in there.
You want as much
brown as you can get.
Now normally when I do
something like this,
I say if you have a question,
feel free to interrupt me.
We're going to take time at
the end for Q&A. I'm having
a rough time seeing out there.
But if I skip something or if
I'm ambiguous, wave your hand.
Oh, they just turned
up the lights a bit.
Wave your hands and just
go ahead and interrupt me.
I mean, let's be friends here.
Because I'm moving fast.
So if you've got a question,
throw something at me.
Get my attention.
OK, we're doing OK so far?
Anybody got a question so far?
Doing good?
OK.
So we talked about searing.
What about grill marks?
All the cookbooks
teach you put meat down
for a couple of minutes and
get grill marks going one way.
Then pick it up and
rotate it 45 degrees
and get the grill marks
going the other way.
And you get this pattern
of crosshatch grill marks.
And you see this on
restaurant menu pictures.
You see it on
packaged goods when
you buy a frozen chicken breast,
a TV dinner or something.
They all show you grill marks.
Well, Maillard reaction is
this browning of new flavors.
So when you get grill
marks, remember,
the surface of the grill
grates, 8,000 times more energy
than the air, it's going to
make those sear marks on there.
And that's Maillard reaction.
That's good.
But look at all the
interstices, the spaces
between the grill marks.
Now, we're supposed to
have Pavlovian response
when we see grill marks.
I see not something that
makes my saliva run.
I see unfulfilled potential.
I see meat that hasn't
reached-- like a child that
never finishes school.
Now the top steak, that's
what I want to see.
That's Maillard reaction,
edge to edge, top to bottom.
That's maximum flavor.
That steak, by the way, is
from a place called prime house
in Chicago, which
won our top steak
award according to "Chicago
Magazine" last year.
I love that place.
And that's the way I want
to see my steaks look.
No grill marks for me.
Maximum.
Now sometimes,
you can't help it.
I mean, if you doing
shrimp, you don't have time
to leave it out there and
let it brown all over.
If you do that,
you're going to have
rock hard, bone dry shrimp.
OK, another myth-- get
your grill screaming hot.
Oh, this is such a guy thing.
Pedal to the metal.
Get it as hot as you
can possibly get it.
Give it all she's got, Scotty.
Don't do it.
We cook too hot.
Use what we call
the two zone system.
You can see on one side,
we've got the charcoal
pushed all the way to one side.
On a gas grill-- I think
that's the next slide.
Let's see if I've
got a picture of it.
Yeah.
On a gas grill,
turn on one or two
burners, leave the
other one or two off.
Hey, how do I make
this go backwards?
Red?
Oh.
I see I've just been
hitting the green.
You told me that
earlier and I forgot.
I thought red was
stop, not go back.
OK, so, two zones-- hot
zone and not hot zone.
On the hot zone, we have
direct, radiant heat.
That's the other type of
heat we haven't talked about.
We talked about
convection heat, and we
talked about conduction heat.
The conduction is from
the hot metal surfaces
or from the outside of the meat
cooking the inside of the meat.
That's conduction.
This is radiant heat--
infrared radiation.
Just like you get out there
on a beautiful, sunny day--
we sat out on the
patio out for lunch.
Chris took us outside.
How lovely.
You feel that radiant heat
on the back of your neck.
That's infrared radiant heat.
And that's a different
kind of heat.
It's not as hot as conduction
from the metal grates.
But it's hotter than warm
air, convection air flow.
On the left hand
side of the grill,
you can see the charcoal
is not under the meat.
It's cooking by convection
flow-- gentle air flow.
And that's where you want
to do most of your cooking.
You don't want to cook over
the charcoals most of the time.
the burners most of the time.
You can throw some wood
pellets or some wood chunks
or some chips on the charcoal.
And you'll get smoke
traveling around in there.
And you'll get the grill flavor.
But now, on the
indirect side, you
can gently heat the
meat I like to shoot
for 225 on the indirect side.
And that takes a while.
It takes a while
to cook the meat.
But how many of you
have immolated a chicken
so that it's black
on the outside
and barely cooked on the inside.
You don't have to
raise your hands.
I know, all of us.
Do this with your chickens.
Put that bird on
the indirect side.
Gently warm it.
Safe temperature for
chicken-- 160-165.
And 165 degrees will
kill all microbes
in about seven seconds.
You don't want to monkey
around with chicken.
Consumer Reports did a
research project last year
that they tested
300 chicken breasts
from around the country.
90% or more had
pathogenic bacteria.
And of those, half of them had
antibiotic resistant pathogens.
Don't want under cook chicken
unless you've got somebody
you don't like at the table.
So you want to put that
chicken on the indirect side,
and gently warm
it, and bring it up
to about 140 or 145
internal temperature.
Use your digital thermometer.
Probe it.
And when it gets there, then you
move it over to the hot side.
Skin down, lift the lid.
Because right now, it's
being surrounded by hot air
when it's on the indirect side.
If you lift the lid, now
all the infrared energy
is pounding on the underside.
And you're beating that infrared
energy right into the skin.
And you're rendering the fat.
And your crisping that skin.
Stand there and watch it.
Don't go for a beer.
Don't go take a piss.
Because that thing
will burn in a hurry.
And just keep an eye on it.
And when you've
got GBD-- golden,
brown, and delicious-- when
you've got GBD on that chicken
skin, flip it over and
get the other side.
And then you're done.
And if you test it,
you'll be around 160.
And we call this
the reverse sear.
You sear at the end of the
cook, not the beginning.
If you sear at the
beginning, all that energy
pounds into the meat.
And it slowly works
its way down in.
And so what you end up with
is an overcooked exterior,
and then just below
it, another layer
that's slightly overcooked.
On a steak, you'll end up
with a dark brown layer,
then a brown layer, then a
tan layer, then a pink layer,
and then maybe in the middle
you'll have some medium rare.
So you don't want to
sear in the beginning.
You sear at the end.
And the reverse sear
technique will give you
even color from the
indirect convection airflow.
Even color, even
temperature, top to bottom,
left to right on
the indirect side.
Then when you move
it over and sear it,
you'll get that beautiful crust.
What you're doing now is you're
cooking the interior separately
from the exterior.
Because you have
two separate goals.
Interior-- safe target
temperature, maximum tenderness
and juiciness.
Exterior-- brown is beautiful.
Crunchy, beautiful,
flavorful exterior.
OK, are we with me?
And the same thing
on a gas grill.
You have one or two burners.
The more burners, the better.
So if you're buying a gas grill,
go for three, four burners,
but at least two.
Get at least two burners so
you can set up two zones.
You want to zones.
And these are just some
pictures of what I showed you.
Look at the bottom two.
The middle one, number two, was
cooked the normal way-- sear
first and keep cooking.
And you can see there's a
layer of well-done right
below the surface.
The bottom one was
cooked indirect sear.
Very, very thin
overcooked layer.
Beautiful, medium
rare in between.
Now, how many of you are
grossed out by that pink color?
OK, too much, too juicy,
too bloody for you?
Too bloody for you?
It's not blood.
The juice that you see
in a steak is not blood.
That blood has all been
removed during the slaughter.
Animal blood is
just like our blood.
It's dark red.
It's thick.
It's almost black.
And if it spilled out, it would
be really thick and coagulated.
It would harden.
The juices that come
out of a steak are thin.
It's water.
And it's pink only because
of the color of the pigments
of a protein called myoglobin.
And myoglobin makes it pink.
And we'll talk more
about that in a minute.
Roast your food
in a roasting pan.
Now this goes-- look at
your Thanksgiving turkey.
This is your
Thanksgiving turkey.
On the left is your
You've got a big old roasting
pan with that V shaped rack.
You put the turkey in there.
And you can see, the
bottom never gets hot.
Because the water in
the bottom of the pan--
you almost always put water
so it doesn't drip and burn.
The bottom is going to
be about 240 degrees.
And how many of you know this?
You bring that turkey
out, and the top side
is beautiful, gold GBD--
golden, brown, and delicious.
And the bottom is
sort of pale and sad
looking, gooey, and wet.
What you want to do
is raise the meat up
so the warm air can
circulate all around it.
And on the right hand side,
you see a turkey on the grill.
It's cooking on the grate.
And the pan is well below it.
Now, air can
circulate all around.
It browns all around.
It cooks evenly.
You don't have it
overcooked on one side,
under cooked on the other.
And when I cook a turkey-- and
this recipe is in the book--
we're going to put
onions, celery, carrots,
a little white wine,
some herbs, and we're
going to put all
that in the drip pan.
We're going to take the
neck from the chicken.
We're going to trim
around the cavity.
Get all the fat off of there.
We're going to chop off
the ends of the wings.
All that's going
in the drip pan.
We're making a turkey soup.
We're making a turkey soup in
that drip pan underneath there.
And it's getting all
the flavorful juices.
Yes, ma'am?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Are you recommending
putting a roasting pan on the
grill, and then another grill
above that?
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: If you can,
depending on what kind of grill
you have.
Like on a gas grill, you
can put the roasting pan--
and I use just an inexpensive
stainless steel or porcelain
pan, not your fancy heavy
duty $250 roasting pan.
And I put it underneath right
on top of the gas burners.
On a charcoal grill,
we're cooking indirect.
So the coals are
all off on one side.
The pan is off on
the other side.
All the drippings are
falling down on that grate.
You can also-- and
I've done this too--
you can also put the
pan on the grill grates.
Put another grate more
like the middle picture
right on top of it there.
And that's a good second option.
And you can still
collect all those juices
and make one heck
of a turkey stock.
And that's your gravy base.
You strain that off.
And that is the most
wonderful gravy.
You won't want to
add flour to it.
add thickener to it.
That stuff just makes it thick.
It sits on top of the meat.
It won't penetrate the meat.
It won't give it any flavor.
You'll just take this
wonderful turkey soup.
And that's your gravy.
And it's fantastic.
But in either case, whether
it's a turkey or a beef
roast or a pork roast,
get it up above the pan
so it can cook all around.
Here, we talked
about this earlier.
The red juice is blood.
It's not.
It's myoglobin.
It's a liquid.
It's almost all water
with a little pigment.
And you've seen it in
chicken and in pork.
They all put that little
spongy material underneath it
when you buy the package in the
store that absorbs the juices.
And it's pink.
It's myoglobin.
OK, big hunks of meat.
Anybody here ever do pork
shoulder to make pulled pork?
Hands?
Briskets?
Yeah, OK, good.
Legs of lamb?
Get the fat cap off.
You're told that the fat cap
will melt and baste the meat
and penetrate the meat.
Because fat is flavor.
We all know that.
That's true.
That's not a husband's tale.
But the fat that's
flavor is the fat
that's woven within the meat.
It's called marbling.
The fat that sits on top of
the meat is no good to anybody.
You're going to sprinkle
the spices and the herbs
on that fat cap.
And then when you serve it,
the first thing everybody
does is cut off the fat cap.
And there go all your
spices and herbs.
This picture here, it's
not my best photography.
Forgive me.
But in the top picture,
same piece of meat.
You can see it's pretty
much the same meat.
The colors are shifted
a little with air.
But the top piece of meat, I
dug a hole in a piece of beef,
filled it with olive oil.
And that's 33 seconds into--
it took me a while to focus.
And then the bottom one
is 10 minutes later.
Pardon me, that's nine hours.
That's nine hours.
Nine hours and 58 minutes.
The fat goes nowhere.
Why?
Meat is 70% water.
Oil and water don't mix.
The fat on your fat cap is
not penetrating the meat.
It's not going anywhere.
It's not doing you any good.
Get rid of it.
If you want, what
I do when I'm doing
a brisket or a pulled
pork or something
that has a fat cap like a leg of
lamb, I'll leave a thin layer.
Because people will eat
a thin layer of fat.
And it will get
really good flavor.
What was the movie?
We were talking about
this the other day,
Carrie-- little kids
asking people at the table,
you gonna eat your fat?
Somebody in here
knows this movie.
It's a Rodney Dangerfield movie.
There's this little kid
like, you gonna eat your fat?
You gonna eat your fat?
Fat is flavorful.
Bone in steak is
better-- another myth.
I know that we love
to gnaw on the bone.
And that's fun.
And that's a good reason to
leave the bone in a ribeye.
But the bone doesn't
give you any flavor.
Now, that may have came about
because if you take something
like beef ribs and put them
in a crockpot or a stew
pot or a Dutch oven, and
you put in your sauce,
you're making up a little
red wine, and some stock,
and some seasonings,
and you pop it
in the oven, or your turn on
the crockpot, that will extract
the flavor from the bone.
But it doesn't
extract any flavor
from the bone in a
dry cooking method
like the oven or the grill.
You can see in the
cross-section of the bone,
that compact bone
portion is pure calcium.
Calcium has no flavor,
none that we can taste.
The yellow marrow has flavor.
But it can't get out.
What the bone does do is it
interferes with even heating.
And it's kind of hard to see.
But you can see that the dark
red areas around that t-bone
don't heat up as much
as the other areas.
Because the bone
is like the heat
shield on the space shuttle.
It interferes with the heat.
Now, as the bone heats up,
it'll retain heat more.
And it actually gets hot.
But the bone doesn't
do anything for flavor.
And it will alter the
healing properties.
So when I'm doing a ribeye, I
will often remove the bones.
Of course, the way
I do ribeye, you
would expect me to do it weird.
I'll buy a whole beef rib
roast with seven bones in it.
And I'll cut the whole
slab of beef ribs off.
And that I will cook
as a separate meal.
Beef ribs-- wonderful.
And I'll then take this
round, big old roast
and cut it in a rib eye steaks.
Now I have my own ribeye
steaks cut perfectly
to my specifications.
I like them about
an inch and a half.
And so I have now
boneless ribeye steaks.
And when I cook them, the
heat enters all sides evenly.
And they cook perfectly even.
And I have a slab of beef
bones that I can cook
for beef ribs for another meal.
Here's another myth-- let
meat come to room temperature.
Take it out of the fridge.
Let it sit on the table
for a couple hours.
Well, I tried that.
I took a steak, stuck
a thermocouple in it,
and waited for it to
come to room temperature.
About an inch and
a half steak, I
think it took maybe three
hours to come to room temp.
If you went to a
restaurant, and they said,
yeah we've got your
steak sitting out.
They've been out
for a couple hours.
We'll put it in
the oven right now.
You'd head for the door.
It is not a very safe practice
to let meat sit around
at room temp for very long.
And a roast, a four
inch thick roast,
takes 10 hours to
come to room temp.
But there's another reason
why you don't want to do it.
Cold surfaces attract smoke.
Just like when you
get out of the shower,
the cold surface of the
bathroom mirrors attract steam.
And your mirrors steam up.
Well, smoke will be
attracted to the meat that
is cold out of the fridge.
And this picture shows
you the experiment we did.
The white can on the right is
the control sat of my desk.
The can on the middle is empty,
and it went on the smoker.
The can on the left was
filled with ice water.
And you can see, not only did
it attract a lot of smoke,
but moisture started
running down the surface.
Wet surfaces also glom
smoke and hold on to it.
So smoke is a lovely flavor.
You can't get it
on your spice rack.
So you can get it on the grill.
So go cold meat on the grill.
And you'll attract
more smoke flavor.
And you'll get more
flavor that way.
Liquid smoke is nice.
It is made from natural smoke.
But it's not the same.
It's gone through
a transformation.
And it's not the same.
Natural smoke fresh from the
cooker really tastes nice.
So cold food, maximum smoke.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
de-frost in the fridge?
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: Yeah.
Well, of course, you do want
to de-frost in your fridge.
You do not want to
de-frost on the counter.
Now, there is some new research.
USDA did some research
that shows you can actually
defrost in hot water.
And you've got to
be careful about it.
And I don't have time
to get into that.
But I do talk about
it on the website.
I think it's
mentioned in the book.
But de-frosting
is another issue.
And there are several
ways to de-frost.
But the best way is just
leave it in the fridge.
If your fridge is 38, check
your refrigerator temperature.
Thermometers.
38 degrees or less.
33 to 38, that's
your sweet spot.
Microbes don't like that temp.
They will not grow rapidly.
You get up over 40,
and they start growing.
And at room temp, they double
in population every 20 minutes.
So you don't want to leave
things sitting around
at room temp.
Soak your wood.
This is another one
that just won't go away.
All the books tell you soak
your wood chips, your chunks
before you put them on
the fire for flavor.
If you soak wood--
well, first of all,
why would you soak wood?
Because you know, they build
boats out of wood for a reason.
Wood doesn't absorb water.
And it's kind of hard to tell.
But I took some
water and stained
it blue with some food dye.
And you can see
in these pictures
that on the left hand side
is the exterior of the wood.
And you can see a
little bit of water
stain on there that
stayed, but not much.
When I took wood and
soaked it-- not just
for an hour or two
like the barbecue
books tell you, but
overnight-- then patted it dry,
they gained about 3% weight.
That's all.
And all of that
was on the surface.
You can see that in
number one, that's
the exterior on the left.
I cut it open.
The wet spot-- you see
the one little wet spot?
It was a crack in the wood.
A little water got
in through the crack.
That's it.
Bone dry inside.
Hardly anything visible
on the exterior.
The middle one is a
raw chunk of wood.
You can see there's a little bit
of blue stain to the exterior.
But the interior, again,
the only white spots
were the cracks and crevices.
And then a little chip-- it's
hard to see from this picture--
but there was no
penetration of water at all.
Now, when you take wet wood and
throw it on a charcoal fire,
what happens?
You wet the fire.
You lower the temperature.
You reduce the temp.
You've lost control
of your heat.
You want to get your fire to an
even temperature, your target
temperature, 225 in the
indirect zone most of the time.
And you don't want to
throw cold water on it.
So there's no need to wet
your wood before you cook.
And in fact, there's
another good reason not to.
There's different
kinds of smoke.
You can have black smoke,
gray smoke, brown smoke,
yellow smoke, white
smoke, and blue smoke.
White smoke and blue
smoke taste good.
The best tasting
smoke is blue smoke.
And blue smoke is
almost invisible.
Let's see if I've
got that slide.
Yes.
White billowing smoke is good.
And a lot of us look for it.
And we say when we throw
the wet wood on the fire,
we see lots of billowing smoke.
It's not smoke.
It's steam.
Wood doesn't combust till 575
to 600 degrees Fahrenheit.
Water boils at 212.
You throw a wet wood on a fire,
the first thing that happens
is you have to boil off the
water before the wood can
combust.
So what you're seeing is steam.
But once you get it going,
white smoke has a good flavor.
But it's not as good
flavor as very pale, almost
invisible smoke.
Blue smoke is almost invisible.
The particles in the
smoke are so small,
they barely refract light.
So it's called blue smoke.
And it's the goal
of pit masters.
Now I hear people all the time
saying, I've got a gas grill.
And I put the wood chips
in a little aluminum pan
or I wrap them up in foil,
throw it on the fire,
and they catch on
fire and burn up.
How do I prevent that?
That's good.
You want the wood to burn.
You don't want it to smolder.
When it smolders, it's
starving for oxygen. You're
getting billowing white smoke.
You want the wood
to burn vigorously.
Barbecue pits, the big
ones, they cook with wood.
They don't let it smolder.
They throw the logs on there.
And it catches on fire.
It's hard to keep the
temperature down once they're
burning with flame.
But that gives you the
purest, best flavor of smoke.
So don't worry if your
wood chips catch on fire.
Another myth-- rubs and
marinades penetrate the meat,
tenderize it, and flavor it.
That's a piece of chicken
I think, maybe a pork chop.
I forget which one that is.
I made a basic marinade,
some oil and some vinegar
and some flavorings and mixed
in some green food coloring.
The green food
coloring went nowhere.
Sucrose, sugar, garlic,
paprika, black pepper, these
are huge molecules.
They cannot penetrate the meat.
They can get into some pores
and cracks and crevices
on the surface.
They cannot get
deep into the meat.
The only thing, the only
thing, that goes deep into meat
is salt. Salt is magic.
Salt is the magic rock.
It's sodium and chloride.
And when they get wet, they
get electrically charged.
They create ions.
And they move.
And they go down.
And you can see
there's a pale line
just below the surface where
the salt has been penetrating.
This was I think
five or six hours.
I forget how long.
But the salt goes on.
And it goes into the center.
And salt works magic.
Salt attacks the
protein and denatures it
and changes its structure so
that it holds moisture longer.
So you want to salt your meat.
But when you put spices
and rubs or marinades
on the surface of the meat, they
don't go beyond the surface.
They flavor the surface.
You get wonderful
flavors from them.
But they're not getting
into the center.
And if we cook this up and
we took a core sample out
of the center,
you wouldn't taste
any of those spices and herbs.
Beer can chicken.
Oh, I've gotten more
hate mail on this one.
This is the one that gets
me the worst hate mail.
We don't have any
problem with trolls
and hate mail on the website.
We have no prescreening
of comments.
People love barbecue.
They love to talk it,
except this-- well,
there's one other page,
the page that says
don't put ketchup on hot dogs.
It's a comedy piece.
It's a humor piece.
It's got a whole bunch
of quotes from people.
I get more vile-- how
dare you tell me not
to put ketchup on hot dogs?
It's a joke.
It really is.
You can tell it's a joke.
Anybody with a
sense of humor-- I
think if you put
ketchup on hot dogs,
it takes away your
sense of humor.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
Beer can chicken.
Everybody know what
a beer koozie is?
A little piece of foam rubber
that you put around a beer can,
and it's supposed to
keep your beer cold?
What do you think a 38 degree
three and a half pound chicken
is?
It's a chicken koozie.
It keeps the beer cold.
You put it up the
butt of the chicken.
And now you have a
large thermal mass
that comes out of the
refrigerator at 38 degrees.
The beer never gets beyond
the temperature of the meat.
It can't.
It doesn't boil.
It doesn't steam.
Steaming temperature
is 212 degrees.
If you cook the meat
safely to 160-165 degrees,
the beer rarely goes above 150.
If you overcook
the hell out of it,
blacken it, and take it
up to 190 or something,
the beer still won't
go over 190 degrees.
It can't boil.
You weigh the can
before, you weigh the can
after, it weighs the same.
In fact, in a few
cases, when we tried it,
we weighed the can after it.
It actually weighed
more because the fat
from the chicken dripped into
the can, coated the surface,
and of course, that
went further to prevent
the beer from evaporating.
So beer can chicken is cool.
It looks cool.
I mean, doesn't
that little chicken
sitting there looking like
a human being look cool?
But then the beer can
chicken devotees say,
but everybody loves
my beer can chicken.
It's so good.
It's delicious.
Of course it's delicious.
It's roast chicken.
[LAUGHTER]
Everybody loves roast chicken.
It's hard to mess up roast
chicken unless you overcook it.
Only it's not roasted
as well as it could be.
If you take the beer can out,
warm air will enter the center.
And it will cook from the
inside as well as the outside.
You won't over
cook the exterior.
In fact, for me, I'll
cut it into quarters.
Cut it up into pieces.
Cook the pieces separately.
That way, you can brown both
sides, not just the exterior.
You can get maximum brown.
And you can temp
each piece of meat
individually and get
off at the optimum temperature.
So beer can chicken
may be delicious.
But it's far from the best
way of cooking chicken.
It does look cool though.
Anybody hate me now?
Somebody out there?
Somebody left a minute ago.
He was really upset.
He was really
upset I could tell.
No.
Another one-- I'm
running out of time here.
I got to wrap this
up real quick.
Lump charcoal is better.
It looks natural.
It looks like God
gave us this charcoal.
Briquettes look like somebody
made them in a factory.
Well, they did.
But I tell you, the
briquettes are just
as good, if not better.
And there's a whole
bunch of reasons.
And among them is the
process of making charcoal
means carbonizing the wood.
And if you don't
carbonize it thoroughly,
which is a problem when you
make it from lump charcoal,
it can belch out a lot of smoke.
And you don't know where
the smoke is coming from,
what the wood is.
I want to control the wood
flavor by choosing my own wood.
Charcoal is for heat.
Wood is for flavor.
So I much prefer
briquettes because they're
known entities of heat.
I really can't take much more
time to talk about this later.
And my final myth is
barbecue is for guys.
There are more and
more women now.
Our Google Analytics
are telling us
that we're running
around 75% to 80% male.
So it's still a
backyard guy thing.
And I don't know why for sure.
I know this.
The anthropologists,
the scientists
tell us that homo erectus were
the first of our ancestors
to cook.
Homo erectus, the
guys were the hunters.
And the girls were
the pit masters.
The first women were the pit
masters, or pit mistresses,
if you will.
How they ceded the control over
fire to men, maybe the same way
they lost control over
the remote control.
I don't know how this happened.
I do know that we're
seeing more and more women
cooking outdoors.
I think part of it
is that women just
want guys to have their fun.
Have their space.
Let them think they're
doing something useful,
that they're actually cooking.
They're contributing
to the family welfare.
Sort of like faking
orgasm I think.
[LAUGHTER]
But more and more
women are grilling.
And I say, let them have it.
That's less work for me.
All right, well that
covers my-- there
are more myths than
that in the book.
There's a lot more
than this in the book.
I hope we had some fun and
answered some questions
and busted a few of your myths.
Do we have more questions?
I think we've got a
couple minutes left.
Well, we started
five minutes late.
Yes, sir?
Oh, wait.
That's right.
I was told to ask you to go to
the microphone with questions.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So I recently-- actually, it
wasn't that recently ago--
but I was asking this
Argentinian guy like,
how come in Argentina you
are such famous pit masters?
And yet your steaks
are always well done?
And his answer was like, well,
that's just because here they
don't really understand how
to cook well-done steaks
in a way that is delicious.
What's your take on this?
Can you cook well-done steaks
in a way that's delicious?
Do they really have
something over us there.
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, it can be delicious.
The flavor can be
on the surface.
But we know that when
you well cook a steak,
the water evaporates.
It dries out.
It also chemically binds to
the compounds on the interior,
and it gets really dry and hard.
So I mean, if you go
into a steak house
where they have a
really beautiful USDA
prime or wagyu steaks
and they're aged,
and you ask for a
well-done, you'd
probably get a
cheaper grade of steak
than everybody
else at the table.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Forgive me, I didn't
see the gentleman.
AUDIENCE: While you
were trying to bust
the myths about
grilling, you had
to come across a few
that were actually true.
Was there any that you think are
really, really useful that we
should continue to adhere to?
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: Gosh.
Well, I think that the
general overall view
that anything you cook indoors,
you can go outdoors only better
is a good one.
I like that.
I mean, it is just
an outdoor oven.
But you've got this extra
element of open flame and smoke
that really adds to
the flavor compounds.
I mean, there's a lot of what
we've been taught that is true.
That does work.
I think briquettes, you know,
they've been around forever.
I think briquettes are
better than lump charcoal
for a variety of reasons.
We ran out of time.
But yeah, I'm drawing
a blank for others.
But the book is full of them.
You have to buy the book.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
just this year, we
have a place where we can
actually have a grill.
And we got one.
And there was this
big debate between me
and my boyfriend over
like gas versus charcoal
and all this kind of stuff.
Ultimately, for various
reasons, we went with gas.
But you were talking about how
some people with gas grills,
they put the wood in like
foil or something like that.
If there's not like a
specific slot on your grill
like there are for some,
where do you put it?
Do you put it down below the
flames, on top of the grates?
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: On top of
the heating elements, as close
as you can to the heating
elements so they'll combust.
AUDIENCE: OK
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: And you can
get a disposable aluminum pan.
I have an old cast iron pan
that I throw down in there.
Find something that will
hold the wood that you can
put right down on the burners.
Get it as hot as you can.
By the way, I'll sign books
if you're buying them.
I'll hang out and sign books for
you if they'll let me hang out.
I don't know.
Can I hang out?
Tell me if I can no
longer take questions.
Can I Chris?
CHRIS: Last one.
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN:
Well, we've got two.
CHRIS: [INAUDIBLE] waiting.
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm curious.
What's a better grill--
Weber, Green Egg, Kenmore?
Do you have like a
favorite preference?
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN:
I have favorites.
I have this guy, Max,
who tests grills.
And he's the real expert on it.
Weber is just as good as
gold, always reliable.
They have inventory parts--
parts inventory going back
decades.
Something breaks, they're
there to help you.
I love their products.
They're not always
the latest, keenest.
Some of the coolest
new developments
are by other manufacturers.
But I don't think you'll
ever go wrong with a Weber.
And they all work well.
Big Green Eggs are nice.
They're a very different
concept, very different
thermodynamic properties.
I think of them as better
smokers than grills.
They're great pizza ovens.
They cook really well
in cold climates.
Not my all time favorite.
I know Green Egg people
are rabid about them.
And if there's
one in here, he'll
probably jump up on the
stage and strangle me.
But they're not my
all time favorite.
And Kenmore, I'm
not too familiar
with the various
models that they make.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: OK.
Well, thank you very much.
And if you did buy a book, I'd
be happy to sign it for you.
CHRIS: That was great.
Super educational.
Thank you very much, Meathead.
MEATHEAD GOLDWYN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]